I saw that you said that I could eat meat, but I've been staying away from meat since my cancer diagnosis, since I read things that said it would be bad for a cancer patient to eat red meat and that red meat especially causes cancer.
Why the change are these things true?
Can red meat cause cancer?
The easy answer to that is no. Can toxins in poor quality red meat cause cancer?
Yes, but can the proteins of an animal cause cancer? No.
Can poor quality red meat filled with toxins from what the animal is eating be a cause of cancer? Yes.
Again, there's stuff on the internet similar to the earlier question that say, you know, no cancer patient should be eating meat every cancer patient should be, you should go vegan right away never eat meat is bad.
There's books written about it. What was that? The China syndrome or what was it?
But that was totally debunked that was that book and that author was funded by PETA.
I just totally disagree with you make blanket statements now there's some there's some honest blanket statements, you know should should cancer patient any patient with cancer be eating a lot of dairy?
Well, probably not because dairy contains growth hormones.
But does that mean that dairy is a driver for my cancer? Not necessarily. Does it mean every every cancer patient should absolutely avoid dairy like they're allergic to it? No.
And to make statements like, okay, no cancer patient should be eating meat everybody should go on this vegan diet or like the question before every cancer patient should be at a keto diet so they're eating tons of meat.
I just think that's wrong. I just think that we were created to have a balance and part of the reason that we can have some health issues not just cancer is because we do get out of balance in our life.
So there is a balance that we need to seek now cancer can be fed through certain metabolic pathways and those metabolic pathways which feed a certain cancer can change as well like I stated before.
So in general, though, should cancer patients avoid meat? I don't think so. I think that's a wrong statement right there.
Should some cancer patients avoid meat? Yes, because if your cancer is fed through glutamine and with iodine, then you should avoid meat.
However, in order for you to make an order for cancer patient to make the specific type of red, excuse me, specific type of white blood cells to kill cancer, they need adequate amounts of protein.
Could you obtain those amounts of protein through a vegan diet? Yes, you could. It would be much more difficult in order for you to kill cancer cells.
You need a subset of lymphocytes that are called T cells and another subset called natural killer cells.
Now those subsets in order for your body to produce those is completely in very dependent upon protein consumption.
Much of the research shows that you need to be consuming your weight or your desired weight if you're under weight in the grams of protein per day, meaning that if you weigh 150 pounds, you need to be consuming 150 grams of protein a day in order to make adequate natural killer cells and T cells in order to kill cancer.
Well, it's kind of hard to do if you're on a vegan diet. So eating a piece of chicken, you know, it's going to give you 40 grams of protein right there so you can get your 150 grams of protein, you know, much easier if you're eating meat.
Now, of course, we're talking about is clean meat as you possibly can grass fed beef isn't going to contain good omega fatty acids, which is very essential for you in your diet.
It's going to contain building blocks for those that have anemia.
Anemia and cancer is extremely common and you can help build back your blood by eating red meat. So I'm not against eating red meat.
We have patients when I test them with the with the cheek swab, sometimes they test by their cancer being fed through glutamated with iodine and we do take away meat.
That was personally my cancer. It was fed through that and I stopped eating meat for a period of time until it didn't test anymore that I went back to eating meat.
I don't think it's healthy for the average person to be on a vegan diet.
But for a cancer patient to be on a vegan diet, when their cancer is not fueled through with iodine and glutamate, I think it's very difficult to get your nutrients and to keep your energy up.